all right keeping travelers safe we know
reed international is seeing a lot more
passengers fly through and it's
important that everything goes nice and
smoothly indeed and so that's where a
new four-legged member of the force
comes in mary jane fellaini is live at
the airport to talk about dorgo and
joey's skills fairy tain good morning
john and heather good morning to you
reed international airport saw
record-breaking travel numbers just last
month so adding dorgo to the team
couldn't have come at such a better time
there are now six explosive detection
k-9 teams with dorgo being the youngest
and newest addition the two-year-old
german shepherd and his handler are a
team they patrol terminals one and three
responding to multiple calls whether
it's sniffing suspicious baggage or
detecting illegal substances it's all to
help keep the airport staff and
travelers safe
before durgo even started here he was at
a training facility in texas
the handler also did a 10-week course
with him in texas to solidify that bond
and then once he comes here he does
a few months of site specific trainings
to get better acclimated to this airport
and what he may see or experience here
the department of aviation isn't the
only one with k-9 teams other entities
like the tsa also utilizes canines now
you may see dorgo on patrol but airport
officials ask that you do not pet dorgo
as he is still a working dog reporting
live near jane valessa live local now